I've been getting a lot of e-mails from people
asking, is Joe Biden a stronger challenger
than Mitt Romney was in 2012, which was the
last time we had an incumbent president up
for reelection?
And I actually think that this may not be
the right question.
I think that this is really more about is
Trump a stronger incumbent than Obama was
in 2012?
I don't think it's as much about the challengers
as it is about the incumbents, because the
power of incumbency has power and it is arguably
more about the incumbent than it is about
the challenger.
Now, we won't know until we have the results.
Remember that in 2012, Barack Obama won reelection
with an electoral landslide, 332 to 06 with
a four percentage point popular vote win.
This is really, really big.
This is possible for Biden or not.
Or Biden could lose depending on how the next
five months go.
So in thinking about Trump versus Obama, as
incumbents understand that Trump's approval
right now, depending on where you look, it's
38 to 43.
Obama at this point in 2012 was around 48.
So somewhere between five and 10 points higher
approval for Obama at this point in 2012 than
for Trump right now.
That's an important thing.
Now, Joe Biden appears to have a slight lead
in some of the key swing states that Romney
was losing at this point in 2012.
That's an important difference to look at.
The economic situation is a really big factor
because a lot of times reelection campaigns
are referenda on referendums on the economy.
In May of 2012, we had about eight percent
unemployment.
Right now, we have 16 percent unemployment.
Now, it's unique in that a lot of it is because
of corona virus.
But that's something that we have to think
about.
One thing that is important from a math standpoint
is Obama could afford to lose a bit in 2012
from where he was in 2008 and still could
have won.
Trump can't lose anything.
Okay. Trump won by 77000 votes across three
states.
That is very different than the situation
Barack Obama had in 2008.
Also, remember, Trump lost the popular vote
by two in 2016.
Obama won by four when he was reelected.
So when you look at the margin that Trump
has, even if Trump simply gets every vote
he had in 2016 and no more, he likely loses
number one, because the population has grown
since 2016.
And number two, because you are going to if
you look at the turnout in the primaries so
far for Joe Biden, it seems that turnout will
be up.
So Donald Trump can't just hold every vote
from 2016.
He needs to add something in order to win.
And so far, it's not clear that that he has
a path to doing that.
So the perspective I have is that Trump is
a weaker incumbent than Obama was in 2012.
And I believe that the outcome in November
is going to be much more determined by that
and the economic circumstances than whether
Biden or Romney were stronger per say.
If you disagree, I definitely want to hear
from you.